remembering british journalist don
phillips and indigenous expert bruno
pereira three weeks after they were
killed in the brazilian amazon
dom phillips was laid to rest in brazil
on sunday
his wife alessandra sampaio and family
members some of whom traveled from the
uk gathered to bid farewell and asked
for justice for the rider and his cause
he was killed
because he tried to tell the world
what was happening to the rainforest
and its inhabitants
his mission clashed with the interests
of individuals
who are determined to exploit the amazon
rainforest
dom philips and bruno pereira went
missing on june the 5th while traveling
to a remote area of the brazilian amazon
pedro was mapping invasions by illegal
fishermen and poachers in the javari
valley home to the largest number of
isolated tribes in the world
while phillips was researching for a
book on how to save the rainforest
this fisherman confessed to the murder
and the police have detained three
suspects
pedera was buried on friday in his
hometown in northeastern brazil
phillips funeral was in metropolitan rio
de janeiro his widow thanked the
indigenous leaders who helped find the
bodies of the two men and those who
supported their cause
this has become a worldwide mobilization
of solidarity a cry in defense of the
environment and the indigenous people
who protect it it brings us hope
the ceremony was just for close friends
and family but outside the cemetery this
group is holding a banner asking for
justice for journalist don phillips and
indigenous expert bruno pereira as well
as for many activists that have died
defending the amazon protesters blamed
brazil's president chaibo
for turning a blind eye to illegal
mining logging and land grabbing in the
amazon and for promoting the commercial
exploitation of indigenous territories
at this vigil in central rio de janeiro
demonstrators called out the names of
philips and pereira they're demanding
the government to do more to protect the
amazon
and hope the deaths of the two men have
not been in vain
monica enacera rio de janeiro